as I'm obviously we're here for hunted
and which is written and created by
Frank Spotnitz who we know especially
for the x-files how big an x-files fan
were you before you signed on for hunted
I was pretty big fan I remember I
remember when I first watched the
x-files I probably would have been about
17 or so in the mid 90s and I was blown
away I mean it was really you really
hadn't seen anything like it before you
know it was taking these outlandish
storylines which really had had been
treated in a fairly comic book way up
until that point and presented them in
such a realistic almost sort of
documentary way that it drew you in to
you know the whole kind of alien
conspiracy kind of world as well as all
the other stuff they covered very very
effectively it was it was definitely a
whole new direction and I was a big fan
the obvious comparison to hunted is
spooks but the private spy world that
hunted is setting seems much darker
hunted great strengths I think is that
it is that it it's seen an opportunity
to take the the genre which is well
trodden let's face it in a new direction
and I think Frank's idea to set it in
the world of private espionage is a real
stroke of genius
and it is as you say quite dark because
it's um it's suggesting that the world
is not run by the government we think it
is but actually by the people who are
willing to pay to have the competitive
advantage over in the business world by
any means you know that basically money
will buy you unlimited power behind the
scenes where it really counts if that
makes sense so it is quite a dark way of
looking at things especially saying that
governments are relevant it's all you
know it's all being taken care of at a
level behind where we think it's you
know power and decisions things are
taking place how much did you know about
those private spy agencies before hunted
came along well I tried to do some
research but they're there they're very
um you know they're very discreet many
of these companies there's some really
famous ones like crawl a big American
one but the more the ones that our
company Byzantium have based on our the
more sort of discreet London ones and
they're they're pretty they're pretty
discreet and for instance one of them
has a website and it's just the name and
a phone number and that's all you get
which you know by modern standards you
expected more from a website so I didn't
know a lot about them and I did a bit of
research which got me so far and then
fortunately we had someone come in who
works for one of them who was able to
explain a bit more what they do and what
the people who work for them alike and
what their background is and stuff like
that is that someone who is also kind of
supervising on that sort of spy side on
the program an employee of the guy who
advised the show yeah who is the CEO of
one of these companies as well as all
the intrigue there's lots of action
obviously in the show and you get to do
some fight scenes too don't you although
I think it's the first time he didn't
that sort of hand-to-hand fighting isn't
it the k-z technique please tell me
about what kind of prep you had to do
and what it was like learning that and
did no prep tool I mean you know you get
the job and then you start the job
pretty soon afterwards that's sort of
her work so all I learnt as I went along
and I did get better at it it's um it is
it is quite tricky to obviously you know
I'm not you're not learning how to fight
for real but you're learning how to look
like you're fighting and even that is a
specific technique that you get better
at and you realize that you actually
have to really go for it you start off
being all sort of naturalistic and kind
of well if I really do that that's just
going to look ridiculous but actually
it's the reverse if you don't really go
for it right look absurd they just look
like people kind of mucking about you
know
so hopefully got a bit better as time
went on but there wasn't a lot of you
know I'd like to say to you that I went
away and did you know six months
training with a with a master in
Thailand or Brazil or wherever they're
into this kind of thing but that would
not be true so it was very much on the
job and we had a great stunt team that
took us through it and were mentors as
as much as they were doubles for us in
the in the actions you'll have a loss of
location shooting don't you and all
sorts of places Morocco Scotland London
what was that like out being out about
shooting and how does it help inform
your acting well it's it's really useful
just like wearing the costume and all of
and you know takes you a bit further
into it being in the actual you know
filming in Tangier rather than
pretending you're in Tangier in a studio
obviously in in in an infinitesimally it
helps your performance and just by
adding background and atmosphere to it
so that it all feels much more real you
know so yeah it's great it's great if
you can if you can go to Tangier instead
of building the medina somewhere an act
and then you know then I recommend it
what's it like playing opposite Melissa
George well in this it's great because
she's perfect for the part and and I
think the dynamic we had going for
salmon Aiden was was very was very true
and very right for the for what we were
playing so yeah she's great to work with
and she's brilliant in the show
you